the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
[Music]
today it's a great pleasure to be with
you thank you so much for coming to meet
me at the campus of the beautiful Loyola
Marymount University located in the in
the travel district of Los Angeles and
of Markham lax convenient up to all
major freeways and it's a great pleasure
to interview you I've had the pleasure
of reading your books for many years I
think you autographed every copy iPad
except for the most recent copy because
that I've read an audio book or listen
to an audiobook give an opinion on
audiobooks you can to get as much out of
an on vehicle you've read access when
you read things you might not get the
same things I get interestedly there's a
bunch of people who've written to say
that they get both you know they get the
audio log and then they if it's because
my books tend to involve you know
complicated visits right you know mine's
tricky things so then you want to go
back you have to certain parts of the
book intended so get both get those a
few books get all three kindle hardcopy
yeah I know a lot of codes for yourself
a lot of people like to play around at
the end that's a big picnic and I was a
standout with this one that's the latest
book your latest opus
I thought your the previous book might
be you know use of all the words it
could possibly use in your glass plane
but this one even even more I think
deeply truly does involve new ideas you
know theories new new kind of modes of
thinking about reality and universe and
although it you know I remember when you
mentioned it on Twitter you're gonna
write in the book and come here there's
a couple years ago and you said you know
this book's gonna be at quantum
mechanics and it's gonna solve
everybody's problems I'm sure
everybody's gonna move sit under same
phone again and certainly we come away
with a much better understanding on
character but I think the book is this
demon
leaving because it's really about
gravity and I felt that it was a very
very interesting and beautiful turn of
events that only sort of partly through
the book you know the requisite
explanation of quantum mechanics is has
been interpreted and could be
interpreted that you turn to a much more
kind of exciting frontier these four
physicists like myself and my colleagues
of course the popular book but but
really did you step is this the book you
set out intending to write two years ago
and you made that famous momentous tweet
you know I the book has a very natural
structure into three different parts the
first part is explaining quantum
mechanics the basics of it and including
a little light introduction to many
worlds and then the second part is a
deep dive into many worlds what it means
wise to develop the alternatives are etc
and the third part is as you said an
exploration of gravity and convergence
of space-time and argument that one of
the things holding us back from
quantizing gravity is that we don't
understand quantum mechanics very well
and in particular the think about things
in the many-worlds way helps us on time
so I actually bounce back and forth when
when conceptualizing a book and when
writing it should it be just about many
worlds or should it be many worlds
building up to this particular view of
quantum gravity and you know literally
with a very short period of time
actually literally after I've written
the first draft part three I said let's
take that let's just stick with just
many worlds because it's a it's a nice
compact Fiorentina story gentle by that
smaller book for you we digestible right
and my editor said you know that he
really liked the idea that you could
show it in action in modern physics good
research puzzle stuff and he said this
it's nice but with all of your dates are
1960 or before that's not as much fun is
when some dates mentioned or 2016 7
right and we have referenced some modern
results but I think p.m. really coming
up with with a way to hook the readers
natural curiosity the quantum mechanics
not gonna plethora of book to natural
yes point out which is unusual because
you know that's for something that's not
well understood and I'm not going to use
the same as line by the manual hold you
are now hold his desk and I should find
them at Caltech you of the Fineman desk
some professors are chair and some are
desk but but in this case you know I
think with all these books and as you
said in your famous field sure
everyone's going to understand my
version oh this is really the first one
there but other books but they tend to
comment have a concomitant description
of the multi version and you get into it
but specifically with regard to Eveready
in theory this is you know one of the
more notable ones that goes into
actually meeting thatõs of that of that
theory and as I said before we sat down
I don't like podcasts where you know the
host interviews he also she doesn't tell
us you know what is ever going to get on
your book the leaves of enough a host
had not read the book these he or she is
gonna undermine your sails and cat the
cat food budget although I want to point
that this is the first time I think in
human history your last book you quote
an ill intent and that was excellent on
in this book you found a way actually to
save Schrodinger's cat from ultimate and
no harm did anybody for hence the PETA
endorsement on the back so I get a
little you know there are many books not
every single one of them but the vast
majority have the philosophy fact isn't
this weird will never understand it it's
a mystery right and I whether or not you
believe my world I wanted to undo that
because that's why I did think to
another quantum mechanics was something
that have a place in the world because I
want to say number one it's not enough
replete students it's just science right
and number two here's a possible way to
make sense of it now you might not be my
possibility make sense of it but it can
be made sense of and
the more important yeah yeah I was
questioning you know whether or not if I
were in your position what I advocated a
young you know science popular science
author bright and hooked about the
foundations of quantum mechanics you
know as a means to find and profit out
I'm not sure I would in the book you
point out the fact that nobody writes
books about the interpretations of
classical mechanics I mean you've
touched very deeply on interpretations
of statistical mechanics to the origin
of time and in the previous books the
origin Higgs boson the universe etc but
I think it's unusual because in our
classes we never sit down we kind of get
pulled a fast one with your physics grad
student or even the undergraduate you
don't need to know the foundations of
Newtonian mechanics is the point up
baseball's to metropolis all some
baseballs travel and it's actually true
that you probably should spend some time
in my only interpretations of quantum
mechanics of foundations of we never did
we never teach it to our students that
way so I find this beautiful you know to
for the professionals in the audience
that this is actually a useful tool for
evening you know advanced during the
first your graduate students that are
curious about quantum information cubism
and things like that but also to
understand what they're doing because
there's a learning quote that you use
awesome shut up in calculate which means
don't say no I know he wasn't innocent
and calculators right and I think that's
right yeah that was for the interior I
actually have the distinction of being
told by none of the clean nineteen Nobel
Prize laureate Jim people's to shut up
and measure when I started asking him to
mimic what he that is the ultimate
gentle get right of course so he laughed
it up and measured the same thing and
that's what we're trying to do and I
think what's so interesting about about
this book and the connections that you
make within it is is this connection
between the small things and university
ultimate quantum things and the
Morrisons Universal if you study and you
know to first order it might be curious
for the listener to hear why this would
be related at all and why should the
very smallest things be related to the
very biggest things that's maybe
questioning you know one part one other
question is how
you know space-time itself the framework
in which utonium mechanics is played out
upon how can that emerge from bottom
again and i think that's that's a key
philosophical point you make in the book
and i think it's i think you'll be
interested to hear your thoughts on how
do we how do we get around this this
notion that this very small things have
almost moment ants and the basement and
the biggest parts of the universe oh
yeah what do you to what do you
attribute this fascinating connection
between the ultra small maybe Planck
scale structure of space-time and the
grandness of the cosmos that we see that
yeah I mean I don't say that quantum
mechanics is not a here universe I think
that sometimes we say that I've said
that everyone says that but a more
precise version of that statement is
quantum mechanics becomes necessary when
you think about the fairies you think
about the very large wouldn't we get the
rocket to the moon you don't need one
okay just to you Tony grab you and you
need each other all together up to the
moon so quantum mechanics is a theory
that has a limit which we call flexible
so I in certain circumstances under
certain conditions when things obey
certain parameters then classical
mechanics is very very good across
speech but that's the puzzle writing the
puzzle isn't why we need Monica
Mechanics for the very small muscles
like classical mechanics works and along
because
classical mechanics is so different it's
a no fundamental leg and this is any
part of reason I love the book is this
is what I'm doing research on all right
now like why is there is possible and
then where to come but you see when you
do look at the literature on this is
everyone cheats everyone knows the world
is classical so they just find that the
classical mechanics in there but they
don't show why it's necessary or how it
could have been the other way they take
certain features of world for granted
like the existence of space right like
three dimensional space up down left
right forward backward please put that
in it right and as you know as a
physicist when you learn this X and you
want to learn okay
learning quantum mechanics was started
with a harmonic oscillator
what do you do they teach you the
classical harmonic oscillator and
there's a process called quantizing a
string right quantization and again
nature doesn't
that isn't service in class the world
haunted and my strong conviction is that
that's why we haven't want ice cracking
because we stubbornly insist on starting
the classical theory whether it's
general relativity or string theory or
anything else and monetizing it and I
think that if we just start with a
quantum your real purely quantum theory
from the start without seeing any
classical superstructure you might be
able to show how gravity emerges from
but guess what that's really hard like
it's not at all clear how to be progress
key well one thing that is seemingly
clear but even there limit hesitate is
the laws of physics need to be pretty
special to get the classical murder of
world emerging at all so why or do the
laws of physics have that property I
really don't know I would like to know
that you know in my more speculative
moments I wonder like is there if you
had a random generic truly unstructured
set of laws of physics could it somehow
break up into different sectors all of
which had classical image or something
like that but I don't really see how
that yeah it seems like he is consistent
you know fool's errand which is which is
you know to find gravity and have it be
quantized but to do the other way around
yeah seems profitable and of course you
explore that in the third part of the
book and I think that is a unique you
know not too often due to my knowledge I
haven't seen max before so to to
proposing our new new modalities of
thinking I think is very commendable
I mean Lizzy has mentioned for the
people who are not expert at there you
know one of the things we talked about
in classical mechanics is position and
momentum position velocity like momentum
classically is just the velocity times
the mass of the particle and then in
Newtonian physics that's the state you
need a position momentum I can tell you
what it's going to do but clearly
they're not on an equal footing right
like the way that we teach it the way we
conceptualize the position comes first
and momentum seems to derive for that
but then you go to this more advanced
supercharged version of classical
mechanics called Hamiltonian mechanics
and the distinction becomes a little
blurry right like positional mentum now
seem to be more difficult and in quantum
mechanics in the formal
they're completely equal you know
there's an operator key for momentum is
an operator queue for position one might
ask why those are letters but okay
there's the letters and they all the
equations they appear in spectra and
that really sort of begins to poke at
you can say blog is it like that why is
there a difference between position
divided so I and the chapter in the book
about that and I'm sure there's no other
books adept at first all you have
aspiring accounts popular sites and I
think it's no even in my popular books I
want to say something something I don't
want to just say here's the stuff you've
discovered and present a pedagogical yet
part of it
but I also want to make an argument that
people can potentially disagree I think
also the fact that there's a there's a
frontier it's not a dead subject that's
not for you know people up with 100
years ago yeah I mean it's been said by
people I think they the gross might have
said well you know we need
interpretations of you know maybe he
said something like this the particles
need particle physicists physicists the
same way that birds need ornithologist
you know I think if I'm gonna get
something like yesterday so in this case
I mean do we need this I mean as you
said Classical period and then promoting
with quantum commutation relations just
about all you get in saccharide are they
classical texts for those of you not
experts out there that we use them for
ship graduate student classes but but
nowhere in it does it say well there's a
whole you know panoply of different ways
you could interpret what is fundamental
and what is the actual entity under
which you know reality is to be ascribed
and I wonder you know in the many-worlds
interpretation is obviously an advocate
and proponent of you mentioned many
times in the book how it's not only
appealing to physicists but it's also
made its way into popular culture and
the zillions and so forth and you know
to to what do you attribute this sort of
pretty dominant kind of I have to be
honest again counsels is against the
ever Arabian many-worlds interpretation
favorable standard which every physicist
and almost every book you've read and I
have read and say we know this isn't
right here's our other is yeah yeah I
think that
forced most physicists if you ask about
their favorite feature on mechanically
would you say to tear frankly any want
to think to work enjoy and Pete that's
bizarre and weird I mean I've had
professional physicists telling me I
don't care what actually happens in
reality all i care is what the
measurement outcomes or the observation
of predictions i don't think that any
twelve-year-old gets excited by science
by saying something i'm going to make
some observational predictions like i
don't care what happens in reality it
you got excited because you're actually
curious about what happens and somehow
we managed to beat that out of our
students so there's this thing called
the Copenhagen interpretation which you
know traces back probably the Heisenberg
or anyone else and no one ever
explicitly says what it is it's kind of
a very fuzzy but it has this it follows
this idea that what we're supposed to do
is just make predictions not that's
what's happening underneath the hood and
if you believe in the real world and
there's something happening underneath
the hood I want to know about it so I
don't think you should be satisfied but
I think that we should let our students
not be satisfied with it right and yeah
we always have this image of the old
ones you know go into this field ones
their product productive career at least
valued serious as a point down on my
Stein when he was thinking about spooky
action at a distance and EPR paradox was
that at the ripe old age of 48 under the
video I enjoyed so I feel you know kind
of perspective compared and mustache and
hair style I want to talk about you know
some of the criticisms that the many
world theory does have but before we do
that because I think that's stay private
NASA
know more about you and what excites you
what fascinates you about why excite I
know that you you know our great culture
man and you're very very light anonymity
your interests are highly peripatetic
they range from theology to deepen the
heart of ask for physics cosmology
fundamental physics but I also know that
you're you're an ordinary person you
were a summated by many different things
human lives one legged it's one legged a
gentleman
I know you're interested in what kind of
things do you do that make time pass by
without yeah I mean you know I'm lucky
enough that there are things that I do
that other people might think are work
that I think are fun like I have my own
podcast right oh my and I write books
you know I it's interesting when you
write books because I know many
professional science writers and that's
what they do for living this right yeah
but they they write articles for
magazines or websites or whatever in men
even heat writing book and I hate by the
articles but I love already ass cuz I'm
like give me a hundred thousand words
Trivium accept people's trades and
that's really good right and you know
one of the reasons why I started podcast
is because I love reading other people's
floats it's very hard to find the time
why the loughing stack of books and I'm
like I'm never gonna read these but it
might need to interview the other that's
why I'm not like a thrill seeker in
terms of you know skydiving your friends
are I like eating good food drinking
good wine just cutbacks marking your
vacation in Las Vegas where we eat
normal food and I play poker right
we just other kind of thing that is
customizing here this is just a theorem
comes up that's right very very often
but yeah that's what I like to do you
know we try to talk to people what about
that speaking and kind of classical
speaking versus debating versus being on
podcast people we don't try away from
them we don't like
comfortable behind the computer
screaming I know dad where do you fall
in that spectrum yeah you know I was as
a kid one of these people who thought
debating was really I joined the debate
team comes beating my high school and I
was terrible but I exactly over and over
again at the same comment but you know
what you're saying is somewhat
interesting but your delivery is sucks
it's jumping you can't give a talk to
save your life and you know I worked
there was like a little place transition
you know there's a moment I can pinpoint
my senior year in high school I became a
good public speaker and but and I loved
being on the debate teams it did help
teach you logic and argumentation and
speech and so forth but I actually don't
like debating as anymore and I think
that is inaudible today I believe own it
to be mentally respectable but I just
went on life after death for example and
yeah I did it serves a purpose but you
know people on Twitter for example are
like the baby I love Twitter as a medium
but not the discussion because just one
sister yes but you know debating it's a
it's a performative act you know I'm
happy to debate with someone like
William Lane Craig or even Alexander if
I debate on life after death with but
not because we are advancing human
knowledge but because we're sharing some
existing human knowledge with the
audience right I think that if you
actually know there's there's a
different thing you do if you have two
people with the same goals of
understanding the world they don't
debate they say don't talk right it
stops right and that's much more like
what I do in the punk sorry like even
when I have people on the podcast quite
disagree with my goal is to let them
have their second and maybe you know
note my reasons for not believing them
but then move on like I'm not there to
show why they're wrong like that just
puts too much stress and a similar kind
of canard leveled against science
authors popular science offers is that
it's not really a serious
as does and you know I got some
criticism along those lines and in my
book which you were kind enough to live
with with the phrase readable which I
thought was you know a little over
something readable I think you were much
more effusive in your praise and I'm
very grateful that you were so but you
know kind of get comments that oh well
you know you you spending your time
writing boats and I'm in the laboratory
Chaucerian sorry in the throes of the
calculation so how do you react to that
how do you have the day job and the
night job and what do you view of the as
the responsibility or maybe like a
professional scientist in terms of
communicating I think it's not just
scientific academics or generally have
this weird point of view that says oh
you are spending your time making what
we do for a living accessible and
interesting to outsiders therefore you
would you are helping taxpayers fund me
well what we'll say is populations were
out Beach or things like that and then
you say okay this person who does it
feel like me and another he or she can
make good really they should come to you
so you know when I said my response I
did not care like you know just to do
you know it is pretty my career in
various ladies is how my career in
various other ways so what can I say
that's what I wanted to so long as I can
do it I'm going to do it and it brings
you joy right yeah yeah I think that's
magazine also mention by the
responsibility aspect need other be not
completely honest if I said that I did
this out of some sense of duty or
application I like it I don't enjoy it
and I enjoyed even if no one read it I
like the right like I really do enjoy
that sort of puzzle solving of getting
the pieces together and you don't think
you realize these things much better
when you bring the book about that I
think I don't think the individual
scientists of any possible to talk
I think the field has a responsibility
there's many scientists what I think
would be terrible you general public I
should say and the hit is perfectly fine
but I think it has a feel you know we
rely on the public especially the kind
of stuff even I do which is not going to
cure cancer right we're really in it for
the curiosity-driven research
understanding how the world works and if
the world of taxpayers and citizenry the
polity comes up with money to pay for
you to discover things about reality and
then you don't tell them money
discovered like what is the pain of that
yeah I'll a colleague are this in San
Diego used to tell me you know we serve
at the pleasure politicians who
currently aren't engaged in any serious
war that requires physicists or
astronomers to engage their mental
capacities in tonight and that Neil
deGrasse Tyson is written about that the
partnership between alliance between the
economy and big military industrial
campaigns I'm going to talk a little bit
just about kind of the places that your
mind is taking you and I think a lot of
a lot of as I see you in the role of a
popular science right resolved that's
one of these but also as a teacher and I
know that your teachings are important
to you a contact in your and your kind
of day job so to speak
did you write during the mania at
Simon's desk but in terms of that axis
of pleasure and obligation and word is
teaching fall this is something that one
one thing we're concerned about there
are firstly Clark center for human
imagination is can you teach imagination
can you teach creativity and as you know
and as I know and many of our colleagues
know science is eminent entry I think to
think of it as is purely analytic and
quantitative aspect of human nature is
not respecting its role as a part of
culture science isn't culture and yet
some people there is sort of a
distinction between whether creativity
like you know brilliance can that be
taught where do you fall in that kind of
axis well I think he knows something
I've come to appreciate that there was a
weird thing that was said to me the very
first time I taught my own course which
is when I was a postdoc actually one of
professors at MIT or as a postdoc who
was scheduled to teach general
relativity when on sabbatical and never
came back
anyone teaching the course so they asked
me as a postdoc to teach general to be
better for worse I said yes and that
ended up bringing the lecture notes
which and returning a book write me in
the world that way so I at the time I
was living you know poor clothes dogs
living in someone's house and absolutely
the top floor of a house owned by this
couple of those psychologists and and
the guy burns on teaching either
professor himself of psychology if he
said you know whatever the subject
matter that you're teaching what your
students will actually take away from
you most importantly is your moral
example and I'm like maybe that's
community I'm teaching general
relativity whether your take away from
me are the symmetries three-month tracks
are private but years later you license
breath and maybe moral example isn't how
a scientist would say it but I don't
know if you can teach brilliance or
creativity or imagination what you can
do is show it right I don't know how to
articulate how to be a good scientist
but I can be an example of a good
scientist the way that you teach what
are you willing to say I don't know are
you willing to do things in real time
how careful are you about doing given
things that are you explaining why
things are one way rather than the other
way how much you care about this huge
building etc all that is at least
probably much more important than the
actual subject matter which after all
they can get the ball yeah I mean I've
noticed throughout that question so to
many different experts you know from
Pulitzer Prize winning heads to Nobel
prize-winning physicist but there is
sort of a notion that you can you can
see she can teach certainly well and you
can inspire but you know potentially
creativity has to be some something else
something else that's that's perhaps
emerging once they're exposed to these
things you know it might be like some my
artist friend say when I made a young
impersonal must be an artist I say go
and paint the master first do that first
understand where it can afford
masters and our disciplinary rules and
member yeah that's exactly right
so I think that's that is kind of maybe
holds true across business aspect of
culture and that same dear colleague of
mine passed away unfortunately last year
hounds parties to say that general
relativity was the you know crowning
accomplishment of Western civilization
always leads up there I want to add one
other thing to what you said a few
minutes ago we're talking about science
you know quantum mechanics I would say
in astronomy in my cases is something
that's a political we should be I would
say you know there's no Republican
constellation over there Democrat
comment officially and you haven't see
nowadays people waiting into politics
and I think sometimes I think there's a
little bit too much of the halo effect
this first club when I was very smart he
understood this we don't lie so let's
ask them about you know what the in
terms of how many nations should be a
part I notice that you have multiple
online personalities you have a
political showing control account do you
believe there is an obligation for
scientists if so is there some sort of
scientific you know litmus test or
whatever that you know an authentic
scientist should hold or do you believe
that you can have in front of a full
spectrum on like yeah I mean I think
it's a little bit of an exaggeration to
say the sciences of the universe
universe does what it does whether our
political beliefs are but science is a
human activity that is embedded in
politics and psychology and hopes and
dreams and loves and fears just like
everything else right and and admitting
that I think is important I think that
there's no necessary connection between
one science and one's politics I don't
think there's any responsibility on the
part of individual scientists to get
involved in politics I don't think that
being a scientist gets you any special
expertise points when it comes to
politics but I also don't think that you
should shut up about politics just
because you're a special
ya know and I think that I completely
agree that you know someone's have been
to scientists they're expounding on
politics that doesn't there's no reason
why the public should spend that much
time losing them even if their Albert
Einstein
likewise if they're a movie star or a
singer is gotten about politics and yet
they do right I kind of blame the
audience for this right like let the
movie star expound all day I'm not gonna
blame them for expounded right but if
CNN wants to report on they're like what
is the known founding constellations
possibly and then just crease my life
it's even ten you see it quite
frequently all they know no fathers when
there's that are in favor of this treaty
or which you vote for that there is an
overlap be plenty obviously ladies board
arms control might be a place where
there's no billeted in scientific some
politically and again I think that
scientists should be outspoken about
politics if that's what they want to do
but they should be judged and how
sensible their statements about politics
are not because they are PhDs right
right anymore some people who asked me
to give a talk about cosmology and then
at the end it's an ethical sometimes
climate change and I would say you know
I hope when you have a talk about
climate change
so NASA mythology they feel you should
consult on a real friend Cosmo was late
but Holton this is two months of shifted
into politics very little bit so there's
no incompatibility there but there's no
necessary so we talk a little bit about
what you do outside of physics and
outside the lab and writing and get back
into the book in in just a bit I don't
want to talk to see I'm more probably
speaking about your as we say in the biz
world you know how you got to appear
today that's right which is more
complicated and all on the cosmology and
confident but teams playing for the
listeners who might not be familiar with
your unique path to becoming Thea's
atheist are going to say
naturalist as he say for one example in
being a physicist I legally weren't
originally intending to be a physicist
when you started off in college if I
recall correctly perhaps I'm wrong but
but you had other intentions no I
definitely believe it's late I don't
know these lucky kids who decided when
they attended I wanted to do so I was
really books about the Big Bang and
black holes
my favorite vocal is a completely
unknown both simply entitled high-energy
physics to talk about all these
particles be created the bevatron into
the sixty so I was reading this in the
late seventies and I wanted to do that
I'd no idea what that meant to do that
I even quickly figured out I'm going to
be a theorist the reticle rises like to
laugh no one's yeah I know and wanted
wanted me in the lab like I had a
chemistry set surprising that I've
chosen figures but you know we from a
long line of steel workers went to
public school knowing like any I like
this and boom so I got a full tuition
scholarship people know but it gets
because it's free so that's what's nice
and they had very good a strongly
Department the cool enough because it's
fuzzy not that great but good enough
that I could just do research
I got public papers out of my
undergraduate research in astronomy but
I also got introduced to a lot of
interesting topics and politics
philosophy and richer things like that
so I became a philosophy minor that
became very interesting to me and
because of former Villanova alumnus was
a research scientist at the
harvard-smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics I got rejected by the
Harvard astronomy but physics department
but the Harvard astronomy department
cooking so that's why I stayed in strana
more even though I'm not an astronomer
like you know people out there like are
confused by this trifling Islamic right
yes so I was in astronomy department but
again I got lucky enough to be matched
with George field as my advisor and at
the time I mean you're super famous
expert in the interstellar medium
collecting physics and things like that
you know hydrodynamics again I don't do
for a living but he'd become curious
about particle physics
and cosmology and so we wrote papers
together we learn together and then got
lucky again because people MIT ID
already know improve the general tivity
and things like that but Harvey's post
on MIT I went to to periodic physics
Barbara a lot of brilliant people
Trinity and so forth I mean even though
you know I should have left behind the
fact that I came along with Steelworkers
like I never got either either never got
good advice we're never gone probably I
got some good advice in there exactly
like not so just receptors need for the
non-expert so I graduated with my PhD in
1993 so if you're on the cosmology side
of things that's right after we
discovered the CMB Emma code writing 250
little particle physics side of things
or the particle theory side of things
that was just before we found duality in
supersymmetry in string theory is
gearing up to help NASA see but the
point is when I was in grad school
nothing interesting to tap in my field
is different so I was a hot property in
the job market just on the basis of
comments three years later I was on the
dumb market again millions of
interesting things were happening and I
wasn't doing any of them so I was not a
hot property in the job market because
people read CEOs metric D branes and
things like that string theory and no
one you know like no one to explain to
me that I couldn't just cut her around
doing whatever I wanted to do you know
no one else cared about so maybe huge
mistake people and I moved to Santa
Barbara for my second postdoc I never
wrote any papers to the end of that
which was just dumb like if I'm in
network connectivity learning and
learning new physics right like I knew
my little area physics but there's such
expertise and brilliance there like I'm
doing like that right now the universe
safe because I was like no but by that
point I was like you know if I want to
get a job as a physicist I need to be
the expert in something other people
care about right what am I an expert it
you know not that many things there was
one thing I was an expert
but no one cared about namely the
accelerated universe because they had
discovered it yet but then in 1998 they
could stomach accelerating worse I had
written a theory paper on models of dark
energy this well-known review article in
Cosmo constant I was best friends with
people in both brewing Brian Schmidt
Adam riess Oliver I someone would buy
that was mentioned acknowledgments of
the very first paper solve wrote super
got thing with a real blue bar and I
collaborated with Brian Adam riess and
the group the first paper on a page of
state so suddenly even though I didn't
do anything I was on the universe change
to the professor like God a professor
should be cause he's versatile utility
so that was hosted over in 1998 I was
hired in 1999 okay I was suddenly
finally they said yes any acceleration
of the universe is a good friend at
least in that case and that's useful
work and get you full employment so let
me turn back a little bit to the book as
I said only to steal too much thunder
from something deeply hidden published
September 10th of was passed here and
there's a Christmas present it's enough
birth many awards including Amazon's
best times of the year and many other
awards herbs on the back from the most
eminent folks in the fields of
philosophy physics mathematics astronomy
etc so pick up your copies and speaking
of contributions to GE T some people
estimate that quantum mechanics
contributes thirty to forty percent of
world GDP if you consider all things
like computers the internet as I said
before as we both you know kind of maybe
hinted assignments ever grow so does
this quantum mechanics need us to
understand it and then what place do the
foundations of quantum mechanics are the
important or is it just to kind of
establish your bona fides your true you
know this is
natural philosophers and you've spoken
about this in the past to the extent and
that physicists will utter the word
philosophers in disgust in tourism so
how do we how do we handle that yeah I
think you know you don't need to care
about the foundations of it's like if
you want to calculate the scattering
cross-section of electron positron pairs
or if you want to build a better
superconductor or whatever and you'll
need to care about the Foundation's the
only means you need to care is if you
care how many treatments it is it
curious right personally I am curious
about how nature works like but I'm not
being on quantum mechanics I'm thinking
about what happened at the Big Bang
which is also nothing to build a better
smartphone or anything like that
right but it is there's a tiny fraction
of us that have the most privileged were
paid to think about the deepest
mysteries of the some philosophers are
abundant right there's not a bright line
in between physics and there's a strong
overlap continuum between them and I'm
gonna I'm gonna take tell wherever I can
get whether ISM physicists or
mathematicians or philosophers or
whatever if I understand so another
another interesting aspect of the book
is that you talk a lot about the reality
of the Eveready interpretation in many
worlds and splitting the wave function
so in further non-experts if you could
just to delve a little bit into what
does it mean this wave function what are
many worlds even though it is not I
would say it's not the you know the core
aspect of the book and that emits an
important part of it takes off most of
the searched each section but still it's
not be able to make conclusion I think I
think a lot of the conclusion depends on
that obviously but but can you first say
a few words about what isn't one of many
worlds what is the many-worlds
interpretation and maybe then what is an
interpretation yeah so it's not an
interpretation by the way you know it's
been called that everyone calls a better
I call a back door
it's a theater like what we're dealing
with now likely to be back in 1964
debating different certifications but as
I say in the book like it's not deleting
interpretations of warranties or
elements right is it's a different
scientific theories with different
variables different experimental
prediction
in many cases and many worlds is one of
these theories and the idea simply every
version quantum mechanics says an
electron can be in a superposition of
spin up and spin it franken but it's the
measure it is either spin up or spin
down but when you're not measuring it
it's both which really can't be a
combination of both and ever if you ever
was a grad student in 1952 invented the
theory said well look you were made of
electrons and also protons neutrons but
you're made of particles that you
certainly believe of a Turkish economy
and as we started a podcast with
everything should obey the rules apply
and exhale you usually and so let's not
do the Copenhagen thing which is treat
you as classical and imagine that you
look at the electron that's treat you as
well so that's I sort of move that he
makes which if it didn't mean down a
certain Road everyone would be happy
with it's right but and wheeler did
concept question for every human he is
missing the way from to the universe
every evidence pieces topic was on the
ground the ground and then you realize
you know but no one stands outside the
first to observe it so I need to do a
little bit better but anyway he said
look if you obey the rules upon
mechanics and even keeps positions let's
ask what the Schrodinger equation the
fundamental dynamical equation on
mechanics let's ask what it predicts
when you measure this electron and again
everyone agrees on the answer to that
question the system you plus electron
revolves into a superposition of
electron with spin up and you saw it
spin up plus electron with spin down
your thoughts and ever it's brilliant
second reinforce to say and that's ok
it's more therapeutic than you know
physicists like just believe that don't
bend over backwards to deny the reality
this is what the equation says what if
that were just true and he argues that
were just true he would interpret that
as two separate worlds because what
happens in bed one part of the wave
function and the other part once they're
created they have nothing to do nothing
that happens one artery function ever
affects the other
so that is if they are completely
different
be severe so the point of any worlds is
that he never put in a bunch of work the
worlds were always there all he did was
say let's accept but the worlds are
there asked whether or not people living
in those worlds would see the kind of
world you see the country's empty sea he
says yes to be sure that isn't
interpretation I mean is sort of an
interpretation I mean saying let's just
see it's ok sort of giving yeah come on
tour that it's okay to treat them for
the purposes of this exercise right for
now we haven't actually come up with a
with a you know to this point in this
particular question we've not come out
and find specific that was intended for
task world's own something that you
would observe differently were many
worlds to be if the theory because it's
a set of mathematical structures that
evolved in a certain way now that's just
like classical mechanics within
relativity or whatever and of course you
have to point to things in the world and
say this is what is being represented
any here and ever it has a way of doing
that it is more problematic than
classical mechanics where everything is
pretty straightforward
so that's fine we can argue about that
but it's eminently falsifiable because
all ever it says it wave functions may
have a distributor all you show me is a
wave function either either a weight
function elevated for or something in
the world is not a wave if you do either
one of those things you have falsified
many volts but when it does apply the
Copenhagen interpretation to instead
Osorio the hated interpretation is I
mean cousin hazing have certainly set of
quantum systems do not obey the
Schrodinger equation whether they is
right
sure and ever since they only smooth and
uniform and behavior right okay so for
somebody that didn't want to you know as
he talked about in the book and a very
acute conversation between the daughter
physicist expert father and says you
know mention your billionaire
billionaire law I'm interested in both
because you know what my experiment
right now assigned observers in Chile
there's no shortage of llamas that we
could actually obtain and there's sort
of billion sighs I mean maybe
Solyndra's you're a billionaire mom and
i want to know how would you go about
actually creating a test that you
couldn't doubt you know the Carroll
Institute of Technology or we're taking
we're accepting donations in season
what kind of unlimited resources people
doing it it's not fun experiment people
doing this experiment get a bunch of
atoms together get them cooling down so
it's like a bose-einstein condensate or
so forth there are theories in which
very explicitly the weight function
undergoes spontaneously without anyone
looking at okay without the sugar your
soda is a explicit violation of the
Schrodinger equation and you can
calculate to that that basically dumps
enemy into the system so it will ruin
the bose-einstein right things the fact
that it's a condensate right so it's
very rare for any one particle to
undergo one of these transitions but if
you have not particles together it
actually happen so like the rate for
particles on the white ones for 300 so
new bunch of particles there's an easy
experiment to do but it's a very clear
signal that we rule out in worlds close
would you say be on to that type and it
does I want to think one other step back
previously you and I are talking about
Karl Popper and the bank's demarcation
you know some position that no proper
suggested that something is not
scientific if it cannot be falsified and
you and I talked about this his original
targets and then you discuss a little
bit in the book as well you know where
things like marxist materialism and I
would point out there's a lot 1/2 just
dictatorships on earth today then in
poppers times they even he's been
falsified but physicists take that mr.
Berlin sacrosanct you know law of nature
I personally think that that always do a
deep sort of envy a philosophical envy
of the girdles the completeness theorem
in mathematics which shows that you
can't make sure that our formal system
of mathematics is self-consistent and so
to me to obtain a parallel structure and
says like we rely on this popper
definition and it leads people to say
some pretty hostile thing but but the
same things about like the multi-verse
and even in many worlds that is not
society because it cannot be falsified
now you're talking about falsification
and you know due respect to my
tournament of colleagues who made
bose-einstein condensates all over San
Diego my laboratories not the coldest
part of San Diego it's pretty close but
six million Kelvin currently but but
they can get on college why when will
this occur any time goes on inside
conferences for 30 years more so what
are some of the practical impediments
behind this is it a matter of time I
mean are the things that come into the
wavefunction splitting the timescales
for that you mentioned 300 years what
kinds of things could we do to
accelerate the discovery yes let me just
mention parenthetically you already read
that listening to physicist expound
about politics should we give them any
more credit than purse on the street
likewise for philosophers I like Asian
language for physicist expounding about
philosophy like I just love to think
that 15 minutes of thought they can
solve all the velocity problems in the
world that's not true so let me believe
he listened to the physicists or other
scientists talk about the scientific
method or these roots not science just
know and this is pre country we can go
ahead and do that but if they have no
expertise whatsoever and but yeah but
even if you take popper at face value if
many worlds is perfectly falsifiable for
exactly these reasons and popper
said good things about me was I had to
put note he didn't agree with it he
didn't like it right he said it was much
better than poking things amongst Ross
yeah yeah he had his own interpretation
of different guesses right but you know
he's not been many worlds philosophy and
it is very impulsive viable now I this
example of getting bose-einstein
condensation looking for spontaneous
collapses is an unusual one one just
because it's so good it's like so
faithful to you if you found this will
be will there other alternatives to any
world
people mean mechanics which is much
harder to see how to rule them out in
drag
there's plenty of people who believe
that they cannot move out there
experimentally indistinguishable from
many buttons I'm not so sure about that
like I think that this is this is part
of the ramifications of factories have
been taken foundations upon and
seriously so we haven't really thought
as hard as they can about these plans
it's interesting to see how Colleen said
UC San Diego Freedman and Kaiser food
that are working with me and others on
so-called cosmic Bell invest and and
some of these have you know really ruled
out as many loopholes or spaces that
could plausibly explains in Maryville so
you know it does seem there's a
resurgence and non-chinese that groups
are very very interested in this type of
work quantum information maybe we're at
the you know precipice or a regulation
when these types of experiments will be
taken you know with the with the
seriousness that perhaps they deserve so
I think it is interesting to note that
this is something that is potentially
falsified well it sounds like you're
willing to grant falsifiability as
having some measure or contributing to a
metric of success of a theory
maybe not the definitive one this popper
might have argued well I think it's
sufficient unnecessary that you can fail
viable then what's your complaint right
and you get that emulsifies you know one
thing I take away from the big picture
your previous book you know is sort of
this this contention that the only that
which can interact with the core theory
and is is real or can be considered real
so therefore you filter guys astrology
and maybe even things like that that
cannot be you know there's no god
particle despite the environment
terminology for it yeah but the question
of you know whether or not these these
many worlds
I mean is there an interaction with them
with the course here I mean can you
overlay the superstructure of many
worlds itself and ask
interact with the core theory or can
advance an email explain what is the
core theory Frank roll chats definitions
will just answer the question of course
but you interacting in these clips they
came from the same place right we share
the same path the world came from the
same place is a very physical tangible
interaction even in the past just not in
the future right so the core theory is
this way of thinking about the laws of
physics that govern our everyday lives
and that's a very expansive definition
of our everyday lives
to basically include almost every
experiment ever done your honor right so
the idea that the world is a bundle of
quantum fields subscribe electrons parts
and neutrinos and so forth interacting
the rules on field theory the forces of
nature of magnetism the strong force and
even gravity at the quantum level is
included here because as long as you're
within a wheat field
weak gravitational field far away from
black holes or the big bang or whatever
we understand bhangra me so literally
everything you've ever seen your eyes
touch with your fingers etc is well
defined well described by this court
here and people continually
misunderstand what I'm saying but I
don't think you do but other people do
it so I'll say it out loud like they
think what I'm saying is that this
existence of this core theory either you
know proves the consul's nature is to
prove the fabric that doesn't exist or
proof it's collecti doesn't exist but
that is right what it proves is that if
you want to believe any of these things
that somehow affect the world in a way
to show up in your everyday life
that you're saying that this core theory
which I get the equation for the faulty
white t-shirt you're saying that's wrong
you're saying it has to be modified with
supplies oh it's so this series been
tested six ways from Sunday so if you're
gonna say it's wrong fine tell me how
it's wrong tell me exactly where it goes
wrong forget about God and all that
stuff but do you think that
consciousness is something other than a
manifestation of physical stuff tell me
where this equation goes wrong that's
your burden because we establish that
the equation is pretty good and could
one not say well in the future we have
just we didn't know if the weak force
and core theory
I mean I was very doing the core theory
of 1939 etc oh sorry just thinking sort
could one say well we don't know how the
soul part of the soul long or whatever
the crouton interacts with the core
theory now like you're changing its
premise of teacher good one not say that
one cannot say that that's the thing
because the wonderful heat it's a
special feature of quantum field
differently if you're talking about it
but in the book I explain this idea of
crossing symmetry that if something can
affect an electron in some way then you
can rotate by 90 degrees and you can
make that thing by smashing electrons
together right fields that talk to each
other and have an influence on each
other can be created or destroyed by
each other so if there were things that
affected the quantum field theory we
couldn't make that they either are just
not there or they interact so weakly
they have zero in our everyday life and
no discoveries in future physics will
change that unless those discover you
say quantum field theory is entirely
well what about the others are acts
obviously the soul was something human
in the center that would have to be a
low energy from those who say well we
haven't reached high enough him you know
you reach ten to six ete be you know
looking at early quantum universe
perhaps today you might see evidence of
some part that's what the other but
that's not our everyday life yeah and so
outside our everyday life in the very
very early universe supports of whether
you're he's nowhere near sufficient and
when you process things at Oxford on the
philosophy theology you talk about God
is not a good theory theory but gotta
get good thinkin happiness pretty good
the title and in the harvester and in
that talk you give a few different
arguments and one of them which electric
issue with was the the notion of you
show the Hubble DT he's like yep let's
appoint all these galaxies if there is a
clear so I'm wondering if you could
maybe we really it's a argument but no I
can say well there's 116 elements on the
periodic table you know and maybe gods
advocate in this case would say well
what is the purpose of any of those you
know why we've made of maybe three dozen
different elements of commodities so I
want to be to you know enter a full
centric when you talk about what's the
purpose of these galaxies at home what
is so as an argument against the
existence of God is a good theory eat
non seasons of God itself but why why is
that sort of a persuasive argument in
your opinion well because good theories
make good predictions and we're thinking
about this as the nation's okay so we
have different theories of the universe
theistic models atheistic models
whatever in the middle subcategories
within there and then you ask yourself
the whole job of testing theories is you
say if this theory were true what should
I look and then you update you have a
prior probability for all the theories
when you update that is saying depending
on the likelihood would yields of hell
observe so if all you knew was that God
created the universe and God loves us
and God has some special place for us
and it's like what do you forget it
should be in large-scale features of the
universe well we've done that experiment
because there were people thousands of
years ago who had this book and none of
them predicted 200 billion galaxies
spread uniformly throughout the world
with no human beings on might be
completely irrelevant to us if all you
needed was to make human Connie there's
much easier ways to do that
and surely money more universes so
either let me just better so either you
say well I have no idea what God
predicts for you say well God wouldn't
predict that therefore Lois and if you
say I have no idea what doctor day it's
you're saying god it's not right okay
yeah so I would say just the same it
might be to paraphrase what you're
saying the the existence of the extra
108 elements or whatever on the PR table
is further justification in maybe
perhaps parsimonious John but you know
you tell me to use a trivial case I'm
you know eight counties in San Diego
who's studying the Hubble Deep Field is
cutting every one of those galaxies and
it might be to advocate the purpose of
those galaxies you know it's for a few
materials we need to understand the
universe pop again I think we overlay on
top of it the the notion
these attributes of God that's that's
another thing but you know perhaps it's
again just just speaking trying to
summarize the you know this is the
excess of these of these elements and
things that we can't interact with or
see no purpose or no it's not clear to
me that that sub that that entirely
invalidates the notion of even
impersonal but certainly thinking with a
personal a God created a created
universe right I don't know that that
necessarily about Rick this is just a
tribute I want to say come on I mean of
course you can after the fact some ex
post facto and this is the entire
history and theology discovery new
theory meet back spoken the person
though that's just how God would have
wanted to do it and never write did they
say ahead of time that's why it's a
crappy okay good so I want to conclude
the last few minutes with the zone yeah
I'll put a bunch of links to that talk
that we just mentioned on the talk about
that links to the book and the other
things that are coming up in ecology
which no I mean this is a podcast but
you know it's the usual thing we're
having to mind feed our guests after
what comes out that has been transformed
so like I'm feeling here here in this is
a very low publication year for me
because I got the book out and
everything I have like three or four
epsilon quantum mechanics cosmology and
the one that I'm really very excited
about statistical mechanics and
causality by the past ladybugs have
puzzled over the future of another past
Julian dudes for the joy of girls ideas
about causality things like that so it's
something that people have mumbled about
liking you can make it big wonders okay
last question dream guest for the
podcast
a line or line today ladies I guess he
can't lay out can't violate the core
theory all right people who are alive
you know I didn't ask this before and
I've never given a satisfactory answer
and Hartigan's I've done pretty well
with getting my dream guess I haven't
Martin oh my god yeah we're pretty good
you know and I have a long list of
people I've not invited but if I didn't
like it they might say yes so you know
I've looked at once and no spell on the
podcast I'm like I brought Obama on the
podcast at me either rule against Korean
politicians or candidates because I
think that they have the best interest
in trying get elected not telling the
truth right probably also has that even
though he's out of office so he probably
wouldn't help either
but the obvious Netflix bush and all
these people need a reason we passed
away Noam Chomsky yeah the one which
Anastasia deletes lady when I don't want
Jennifer a little bit disappointed she
thinks oh right she's supposed to say no
children of the physicist she wants to
say she must be a lie down for my speech
he can even culturally England but much
happier at home with the cats right let
me show you the book one more time out
Aaron Hilbert space Hilbert space appeal
probably real okay so the universe is
realized element get the book
audio-visual
Kimbo any form possible something deeply
hidden by dr. Sean Carroll assist that
California Institute of Technology
Thank You Sean alright thanks Brian the
only thing that can be sure of about the
future is it will be absolutely
on
[Music]
you
you